Brothers and sisters, just imagine for a
second that you give £10 in donation and
that £10 is used to buy food or bricks
or whatever to help the people in Gaza.
But then just imagine this amazing thing
that you want to do, but we turn it into
a money-making machine. How? The Waqf is
exactly that. They take your money and
the money that we are going to put in in
this Waqf, this building, and every
single time the money generated from
that Waqf, that building, is going to go
to our Palestinian brothers and sisters
for the next 20, 30, 40, 50, 60, 100,
150 years. And this will be a form of
true Sadaqah Jariyah. I myself will be
donating for that, inshallah. Click the
link below and donate. May Allah Subhana
Wa Ta'ala bless and preserve you guys.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh, brothers and sisters and dear
friends. Hope you guys are well,
inshallah. So, me and Zeeshan been
watching this video of uh a individual
which
we don't know if they've been identified
or not identified, but it seems like
there is some eyewitnesses and
especially of the auntie whose hijab was
ripped off, who said that this was the
woman who done it. So now we're going to
be talking about that cuz this vile
individual who actually allegedly All of
this is allegedly, yeah. Yeah. Chance uh
democracy um and um what does she
understand by the democracy? Ripping
people's hijabs off? And what does she
use an excuse? Apparently what's going
on in Iran. So apparently in Iran they
are forcing you to wear a hijab. So
therefore in a democratic country we are
going to take off a hijab.
Yeah, it's like saying, "Yeah, uh in my
country they're forcing you to wear your
seatbelt. So we're going to come to your
country and take your seatbelt and force
forcefully take it off Yes. to random
strangers."
Yes, nice. Yeah? It's a democracy, but
apparently she's confusing democracy
with uh anarchy. Cuz in an anarchy you
go and you do whatever you want. In a
democracy they follow
harm principle. Exactly. So And
religiously aggravated assault is
against the law. It's against the harm
principle, whether you're what is it?
Kant uh Kant's categorical imperative or
utilitarianism, whatever philosophical
way you want to go, it's wrong. Yes. So
this woman coming and applying her one
IQ logic and uh you said in it she's a
Iranian Jewish lady. Uh She's actually
fled Apparently
Apparently she's Jewish. Yeah,
apparently Well, and she's fled to
Israel. Well, here's the video of what
she was doing, basically. Let's just
watch that quickly.
So guys, you saw that, subhanallah.
So prefacing it,
Yeah. she has said that's not her. Yeah.
The news are saying it's unconfirmed,
the police are saying it's unconfirmed.
There's a picture of her in a London
ambulance paramedic
Yeah. cos- well, clothes
Yes. and they've rejected that she's
ever worked for them. So there's a lot
of unanswered questions here, but one
guy um
he's online called Sayed Ali Shubairi. I
saw his video on Twitter and he's saying
he's in contact with the family and the
auntie and the auntie confirms that it
is indeed this woman. And it's this
woman
whose name is Bahar Maharoo
and she was apparently the first one
that posted it with the message of
democracy that you said. So that's why
we're using the word allegedly, but
according to him the victims have said,
"Yeah. Yeah, yeah, it's her."
Yeah. And funnily enough she's uh run to
um
the most the the only democracy in the
the Middle East.
Middle East, yeah. She's For some odd
reason uh they are just known to always
attack women and children. So she's gone
to the hub of where they give you safety
when you attack women and children. And
subhanallah, what does in the Quran in
Surah Buruj about this? So Allah says in
the Quran in Surah Buruj that Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala says,
"And cursed were the people of the ditch
of fire fed with fuel, when they sat by
it and they witnessed what they were
doing to the believers and they had no
fault except that they believed in Allah
the Almighty, worthy of all praise, to
whom belongs the the dominion of the
heavens and the earth and Allah is
witness of all things. Very very those
who put the trial of believing men
put into trial the believing men and
believing women, torturing them and
burning them and they did then they did
did and they do not turn in repentance.
Then they will have the torment of hell
and they will have the punishment of the
burning fire. So Allah is telling us an
incident that happened very, very, very
long time ago, okay? Thousands of years
ago, maybe hundreds of years ago,
subhanallah, yeah? Allah is saying that
there were group of individuals who made
a ditch and burnt the men Muslim men and
women. Why? What was their punishment?
What was the bullying for? What were
they being attacked for? No other reason
because they say la ilaha illallah. This
statement here is the reason why people,
generation after generations, thousands
of years since Adam, brothers and
sisters, have been persecuted for no
other reason. Even the people like the
the seven boys from the cave, yes, who
ran away. Why? Cuz they said we don't
want to do idol worship. They ran away
so much so that Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
looked after them. And anytime you put
Allah's commandment first, Allah looks
after you. In the same Surah, Surah
Kahf, when you read it, when the
Dhul-Qarnain, if I'm not mistaken,
Khidr, is Khidr do a with one Musa went
to.
Yeah, Khidr. It's Khidr, yes. Some say
he was a prophet or whoever it was for
that reason, yeah? If you notice,
subhanallah, he goes to a specific um
a a tipped over not building, but a
wall. Wall, yeah. And he goes and fixes
it. And what What was the reason that he
done it? Cuz when Mo- Musa Alayhis Salam
said like, "Why did you need to do
this?" What was the explanation he
gives? He goes, "Cuz the father was a
righteous person." Which is interesting.
You know what that means? That means
that Allah takes care of you if you're a
righteous person, he takes care of your
offspring even when you are dead. He
sends a specific individual, which means
what? What do we learn from this? As
long as you stick to the commandments of
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala, Allah will
never let you down. And those people who
And we're talking about the Quran Quran
burner
in Sweden, was it?
Yes.
What? Yes, him. What did he do when he
heard about this situation? You know
what he said?
He His post was,
"I like it." Good.
"What is your opinion?"
Good. This is the reason why I say I'm
proud of it. This is the reason why
Islam puts capital punishments in place
for such individuals. Why? Because you
can see the hate, bro. It's not just "We
don't like Islam, we're just going to
leave and go." No. Islam knows very well
these individuals are going to
perpetrate acts of violence against
Muslims.
That's why the capital punishment in an
Islamic country, which we don't have
today, uh applies. Yeah, and capital
punishment is circumstantial, it's not
vigilantism and it's not anybody Of
course you can't you can't It's not you
It has to be done by an emir. Yeah. It's
not you can't be going I don't know what
people think this is, yeah? But yeah,
that's all I want to say, inshallah. And
for the Muslim women who are watching
this, please be vigilant. Please be
careful, inshallah. Um and
Yeah, I mean um you have a right to
defend yourself. I mean, if a sister if
someone tries to rip your hijab off, um
you have every right to rip something
else off. And and this is something
that's very important because she is
bigging up democracy.
Yeah. And she's saying, "Yeah, we have
democracy over here." The people over
here
are are so frustrated with the democracy
that's over here. Rishi Sunak was not
voted for by the public. Yeah. That's
number one. In the House of Lords,
people that can delay legislation who
are literally put forward by people that
are already in power or positions of
power, they're not voted for by the
public in the House of Lords who
contribute to the forming of
legislation. These people are not voted
in.
Criminals, yeah, children, yeah, people
without ID can't go and vote. So there
is definitely issues when it comes to
democracy over here and it's not
necessarily being meted out the way even
people over here expect it to be meted
out. In fact, the Zionists have got
their clutches
to in the Conservative Party, the Labour
Party, the Lib Dem Party. All three of
them have got the Labour Friends of
Israel, Labour or Lib Dem Friends of
Israel, Conservative Friends of Israel.
In fact, Trevor Chinn, Gary Lubner have
given hundreds and thousands, if not
more than that, to lobby
the the governments.
How is that democracy? I don't
understand. A foreign government or
foreign agency
Influencing who will come into power.
How is that democracy? You're buying a
way in. And and this is very interesting
because here again is a Zionist woman
coming to this country and pulling off
the hijab, denying it's her, and then
running off, scurrying off back to well,
running off back to Israel.
a crap hole. Now, here's what's
interesting. You might say, "Oh, this is
What What are they saying?" Well, I'll
tell you what we're saying and I'll tell
you the precedent for that as well.
There was something called the Lavon
Affair, yeah? L A V O N or double V O N.
The Lavon Affair was when you had
certain Israelis that were in Egypt,
yeah? They started attacking
British and American institutions just
so the Egyptians would fall out with the
Americans, yeah? So they were doing
false flag attacks in which they were
attacking their own allies.
Yeah. What sort of places were they
attacking? Post offices, cinemas. Yeah,
these innocent civilians.
They did. But here we're talking about
civilians here being killed just so they
can, you know, create discord between
two because you had Jamal Abdul Nasser
and the Egyptian government, they were
getting close with the Western nations.
So we know Israel is capable of this and
here is a very interesting example where
they've come and sowing discord at a
time where election time is peak. You've
got the Reform Party, you got the
Conservative Party. They're not going to
be condemning. Watch. They're not going
to be condemning this attack because
it's not good for their vote base.
They're not going to be condemning it.
Exactly. And not only that, like in
Australia, I think Australia, Fatima
Payman who's part of the Labour, she was
in the Labour Party because she voted
something to do with Palestine, yeah?
She was she was sacked. She was
dismissed. And this was in Australia. I
mean, you cannot you're you're part of
the parliament and you are saying I have
the right to vote for Palestine or
something along those lines and she
loses her job. I mean, what kind of
democracy are you talking about? Many
people in in the
in the Labour Party,
the same happened to them here in the UK
also. They got so there is no democracy.
It's it's a lie. It's a big fat lie.
That's what I'm going to say and
sisters, please be vigilant and careful
inshallah. And any woman that tries to
come and rip your hijab off, sisters,
please deal with her. I mean,
in legal ways. You have every right to
damn defend yourself. Okay, make sure
you're not going to just going to get
away with that. Okay? And best believe
whoever's watching this, you know, come
come try that with men, you know, we
don't have hijabs on but you know, maybe
try to take our touch our beards, you
know,
maybe they would end up having a long
sleep cuz they're tired. Amen to that,
brother.